ein Interview mit der bunten von unserer
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser und
jetzt danach eine heftige Debatte den
faesar sagt in diesem Interview glasklar
Politiker sollten einen richtigen Beruf
haben ja sie sollten also was Richtiges
gelernt haben ganz genau so sagt sie es
nämlich grundsätzlich finde ich dass
jeder Politiker eine Ausbildung haben
sollte in die er oder sie zurück kann
das macht unabhängig und freier in den
Entscheidungen Politiker sollten
richtigen Beruf haben unser Bild
politik-chef Jan Schäfer bei uns siehst
es auch so ja das ist glaube ich ganz
ganz wichtig zum einen sollte man immer
ein bisschen über das auch Bescheid
wissen was man über das man spricht also
wenn jemand beispielsweise im
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages sitzt
oder im ernährungsausschuss dann glaube
ich ist es gar nicht so schlecht wenn
derjenige oder diejenige dann auch weiß
ein bisschen über die Materie und was
geht es da eigentlich was sind die
Probleme warum ist 1 + 1 2 und nicht
drei um sie jetzt mal etwas flapsig zu
formulieren dann ist ja glaube ich ein
zweiter Punkt den die
Bundesinnenminister eine anspricht ganz
ganz wichtig man hat natürlich eine
Unabhängigkeit wenn man weiß dieses
Mandat dass man als Politiker hat das
ist ja immer nur alles seit und man kann
abgewählt werden was ja Kernelement auch
der Demokratie ist und es macht
sicherlich viel viel freier wenn man
weiß danach fällt man nicht in ein
tiefes Loch und muss Hartz IV beziehen
sondern kann in irgendeiner Art und
Weise in einen gelernten oder studierten
Beruf zurückkehren und das ist das was
nennt sich viele Sachen das ist
elementar wichtig leider gibt es einige
auch Politiker in maßgeblichen Position
bei denen das nicht der Fall ist das
wäre das nächste Frage gewesen es gibt
ja also
Berufspolitiker das ist ja an sich schon
Beruf aber es gibt tatsächlich einige
die eben nichts gelernt haben wer sind
da Beispiele genau weil du auch gerade
sagst Berufspolitiker das ist ja
eigentlich nicht das was wir wollen wir
wollen ja eigentlich Repräsentanten der
Bürger haben und das sind in der Regel
ganz ganz viele unterschiedliche
Menschen mit unterschiedlichen Berufen
vom sage ich mal Lehrling auch vom
vielleicht malerlehrling bis hin zu
einem jemand der sein stud gerade fertig
gemacht hat aber dann auch bis hin zu
wirklich top ausgebildeten oder auch
sehr erfahrenen beschäftigt und jetzt
die Namen und jetzt die Frage wer ist es
zum Beispiel die beiden grünen
Vorsitzenden Ricarda lang und auch
ominori pur beide Vorsitzende einer
Partei die in dieser Bundesregierung mit
regiert haben kein abgeschlossenes
Studium nur noch keine Lehre absolviert
also da haben wir zwei die in dem Fall
ungelernt sind die eigentlich nur
parteikarrieren gemacht haben wir haben
den
spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert
beispielsweise der sich erst in ein
Studium an der Freien Universität in
Berlin eingeklagt hat das dann
abgebrochen hat dann im Call Center
gearbeitet hat also ohne Ausbildung dann
noch mal ein Studium an der
Fernuniversität Hagen begonnen hat das
hat er auch abgebrochen also das liegt
auf Eis muss man sagen oder nehmen wir
katrin Göring-Eckardt immerhin
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin hat ein
theologiestudio angefangen das aber am
Ende auch abgebrochen also wir sehen
dass es auch in der Spitze in der
deutschen Politik doch wirklich viele
Politiker gibt die die nichts richtig
gemacht haben das heißt das jetzt was
sagt das jetzt in vielen Fällen aus
speziell Kevin Kühnert oder grünen
Spitze auch war das sozusagen last exit
die Politik weil es nirgendwo anders
geklappt hat oder ist Politik am Ende
doch so speziell dass man das eben als
ja Berufung leben muss ich glaube dass
diejenigen die jetzt auch keinen
Abschluss haben ein großes Interesse
daran haben Politik so speziell zu
machen dass man diesen Spruch ich glaube
nicht dass er richtig ist Politik ist
ein Lehrberuf dass man den auch ernst
nimmt aber ich glaube es ist genau
umgekehrt es sollte viel mehr die
Möglichkeit geben in die Politik als
Außenseiter oder als Außenstehender
hineinzukommen dort die Dinge die ein
selbst umtreiben oder die man auch von
Verwandten Freunden von Arbeitskollegen
mitgenommen hat in die Politik
einzubringen und am Ende nach ein paar
Jahren auch wieder auszuscheiden und in
seinen Beruf zurückzukehren so und
deswegen ist der Politik sicherlich eine
Droge für viele Menschen es gibt ja auch
dann Politiker die ihr Studium abbrechen
weil sie einen Mandat bekommen in einer
Partei beispielsweise war es bei Ricarda
lang auch und bei ominoi sagt das auch
was auch die Partei aber sind das
wirklich die Politikerinnen und
Politiker die wir haben wollen also
wissen die am Ende wirklich was die
Menschen bedrückt was wie auch
Wirtschaft funktioniert sehr
entscheidend zu wissen wie funktioniert
eigentlich Wirtschaft wenn ich nie in
einer Firma gearbeitet habe wie kann ich
denn eigentlich dann wissen wie
Zusammenhänge wirklich sind und es
wundert mich deswegen auch nicht dass da
immer wieder Dinge auch gesagt werden
bei denen jeder der ein bisschen Ahnung
von Wirtschaft hat sagt ja wie kann denn
sowas bloß in die Welt hinaus posaunt
werden also heftige Debatte nach dem
bunten Interview der Innenministerin Jan
Schäfer ganz herzlichen Dank an dich
[Musik]